im norden von bosnien herzegowina
versuchen tausende migranten und
flüchtlinge in die europäische union zu
gelangen
einige von ihnen wurden im
flüchtlingslager lipa untergebracht das
wurde einen tag vor weihnachten
angezündet bewohner hatten das feuer
selbst gelegt sie fühlten sich von ihren
regierungen und hilfsorganisationen im
stich gelassen
[Musik]
manche sehen ein problem bei den
hilfsorganisationen die ihnen beistehen
soll
nun sind etwa 800 alleinstehende männer
ins ausgebrannte lager zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
sie entzünden feuer um sich zu wärmen
ihre hoffnung ein leben in der
europäischen union
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren